thanks
Vicky morning everyone great to see you
and great to be here at Chelmsford
Boxing Club and I used to be actually
involved in a boys and girls club in the
past and I know what an incredible job
you guys do to provide services for
young people so thank you for doing that
makes a huge huge difference as I've
seen myself now at the beginning of the
year I set out some priorities and I
always said that your priorities and my
priorities are the government's
priorities and they're pretty simple and
they're behind me it's the half
inflation grow the economy reduce debt
cut waiting list and to stop the boats
that's what we're busy getting on doing
and I'm really confident that over the
course of this year you are going to see
that we are delivering for you and for
everyone else on those five priorities
but alongside that I also want to make
sure that we have a country where all of
us our families our kids are growing up
in strong communities communities that
feel safe communities that are thriving
communities that we all feel proud to
call home
from communities are built on values and
in fact the most important rule that we
teach our kids is the Golden Rule right
it's about respect it's about treating
others in the way that you would like to
be treated back and unfortunately as
Vicky was just talking about right there
is a small minority of people who break
that Golden Rule and cause disruption
and disorder in their communities and
you know what I'm talking about you've
all seen it
about gangs Gathering being disruptive
being drunk being disorderly people
littering graffiting fly tipping and
that's not it's not okay right it's not
okay for a oh
experience it for us as families to not
be able to walk around freely in our
communities avoid Parks or high streets
of particular times of the day you know
that's not the type of communities that
you want it's not the type of country
that we are and that's why it's
important that we do something about it
now of course we're putting 20 000 more
police officers on the street and we're
making great progress on that record
numbers here in in Essex uh but that you
know that's great but we really want to
focus specifically on anti-social
behavior and that's what today's about
and you've got a copy of our new action
plan on your chairs but there's a guy
I'll just highlight what's in there for
you there are kind of three buckets of
it the first is that we need to make
sure that we give antisocial Behavior
the urgency
that this subject deserves so what we're
going to do is use far more hot spot
policing where we make sure that our
police Target the areas that are of most
concern it's been proven to work in lots
of different places and we're going to
have more use of what's called immediate
justice so that those people who are
behaving irresponsibly and poorly will
have to repair the damage they're
causing clear up the mess that they've
made within days of that having been
caught so that Justice can be seen to be
done that's what media Justice is about
so that's about treating ASB with the
urgency it demands the next thing is to
have a zero tolerance approach to all
forms of anti-social behavior and
especially I'm talking about drugs so
what we're going to do is Ban nitrous
oxide because I think all of us for far
too long have had to walk through places
or the canisters and all the rest of it
and that's not acceptable so we're going
to ban nitrous oxide and we're also
going to expand the power of the police
to do drug testing on a rest for far
more crimes and far more drugs and
tackle the scourge of drugs and then the
third thing in the plan is to give the
police and local authorities the tools
and the powers they need to combat
anti-social Behavior so we're
significantly increasing in some cases
doubling the fines that local
authorities councils can charge for
things like fly tipping littering
graffiti we're making it easier to evict
anti-social tenants
and we're investing more money in the
provision of Youth Services like this a
million extra hours for youth clubs to
provide other things for young people to
do and investing in communities to build
more parks and green spaces which are
shown to have a real impact on people's
well-being so that is the plan there's a
lot more in there but that's a plan in a
nutshell got immediate Justice Hot Spot
policing a ban on nitrous oxide more
drug testing and more investment in
Youth Services more investment in green
spaces and more powers for local
councils because this is really
important I know it's important to you
and your families is important to me and
the government and this plan is how we
are going to Stamp Out anti-social
Behavior it's how we're going to level
up across our country and most
importantly it's how we're going to
build strong and thriving communities
that we are proud to call home so that
in a nutshell is what we're here to talk
about today thank you very much for your
time
[Applause]
right I'm going to throw it open feel
free to ask me anything you want that's
what I'm here for we should talk about
ASB a bit because that's important in
topical but anything else on your mind
as well I'm here for anything and
everything so I'll throw open and who
wants to go first yes sir
thank you um prime minister your your
expert advisors on drugs say that
criminals from the media I am yes you
know what we're going to come to your
questions at the end if that's all right
why don't we do that so I want to try
and get some questions from the audience
we've got plenty of time for media
questions at the end right perfect right
so who do we have we have uh yes sir
here
prime minister how do you go about
reporting me on your social behavior and
shoplifting and if it's the
non-emergency phone number have you ever
tried that non-emergency phone number
it's much frustrating thing in the world
yeah no that is a very good point and
you know one thing when we were putting
this plan together you know what you
just said we heard a lot from people and
you know actually if you look at it
oddly enough police recorded incidents
of antisocial Behavior are down 35 in
the last year or so the last couple of
years so you think gosh we're making
really good progress and actually when
you talk to people what's clear is tons
of it is not going reported because too
many people feel exactly the way that
you do they're like it's too difficult
what's the point and no one would
anything about it right and that's what
we're trying to fix so one thing you'll
see in there is what we're going to roll
out is a new digital tool that it's
going to make it far easier for people
to report antisocial behavior and
actually to be able to do it digitally
and online and then get an update on
what's Happening about it now we're not
going to do that overnight so we're
going to have to build that over the
course this year and roll it out but
it's going to address the problem that
you raised right because it should be
easy when you see something happening it
should be easy for you to say this is
what I've seen this is what's going on
and then have the local Authority and
the police report back on what they've
done about it so that you feel that your
concerns are being listened to yeah
thing is there it takes seconds for the
antisocial to take place or shoplifting
time you reported online it goes to
wherever this happened they've gone so
what you do then we we've had a loads of
problems at local market here
report to the police you can set your
watch on it every Saturday afternoon and
this Saturday twice by setting the fire
alarms off congruency to all our
businesses life because they've got
going investigate fire along
they reset the fire alarm
then what's your half hour later they've
done it again for this time they've
pressed two fire alarms and there we are
trying to earn a living all right in
these rough times
and all the customers are now gone
and then we we can't do nothing like
it's so frustrating all right I'll just
at the end of October no look and that's
what I talked about at the beginning
about having high streets and town
centers that are thriving right because
you're trying to work hard and run a
business people want to come and do
their shopping and if it's not safe if
it doesn't feel safe none of that's
going to happen and one of the things I
was talking to the police about this
morning in your local areas this concept
of hot spot policing and we're doing
that's what we're going to roll out far
more of including here in Essex I said
you're pleasing crime commissioner
nodding away and Hot Spot policing is
about exactly that it's about us knowing
what you just said because in every area
there's things like that that are
happening that we know about right and
when it comes to anti-social behavior
when it comes to things like shoplifting
in general there are patterns to it and
there are Pockets where it is more
prevalent and the use of hot spot
policing has been shown to work across
the UK but also abroad as well and we're
going to be doing more of that so we're
investing more in Hot Spot policing that
will hopefully address things like like
that the areas where we know it's
happening the times that we know it's
happening the people that we know are
typically committing it and Target our
resources on those people to make a
difference because I want you to be able
to go and do what you want to do which
is going to work hard make a living and
serve your customers and it's too hard
if your life is being disrupted by
criminals it's not acceptable believe
you me we want to clamp down on it and
part of this plan The Hot Spot policing
is going to help do that and then the
digital tool for people to report it
quickly and get it dealt with as well
all right good all right
um right who have we got yes ma'am
prime minister we work with vulnerable
youth across Essex many of them are
dropping out of school because they're
not coping either through learning
difficulties family problems and I think
that those are the young people we often
see falling into the age of crime or
into criminal Behavior so my concern is
I'm I welcome what you're doing of
course because I think it's important
for Community safety however I do think
we need to look holistically at the
problem as well and try and get
underneath what is it that drives young
people into antisocial behavior and I
think community policing is huge you
know we've seen police officers who know
the family know the children know the
problems and get into that and I think
if we try and just go for the top I
think we're going to miss getting to
that really deepened causation of what's
driving this Behavior so definitely
learning disabilities dropping out of
school not having enough to do family
breakdown Etc seems to me to be one of
the biggest causes so is there a way to
make sure that schools are going to to
have some extra community policing
support so they're able to actually get
to the bottom of where people are
struggling yeah no it's a really really
good point and you know we focus a lot
on the police aspect of this and I was
with the police are there to deal with
the enforcement and the criminal
behavior and it's important that they do
you know because that's their job and
they need to make sure that they do that
but equally it's important that we do
all the other things that we need to do
to try and stop the crime happening in
the first place and you identified a
couple of things there that we are
making progress on that I just want to
make sure you guys all know so you
talked about mental health in schools
for example it's one of the you know
actually one of the very sad legacies of
covid and you talk to anyone who's
involved in schools the increase in
young people's mental health that we've
seen over the last couple of years I can
see lots of you nodding right
um so actually that we're in the process
of rolling out for all schools funding
for them to have access to a mental
health Community lead in the school
working with their young people right so
that is we're work in progress but we're
making good progress on that that will
really help you also talked about youth
provision and you know one of the things
really important in the plan is extra
funding for a million more hours of
Youth provision you know like clubs like
this do a fantastic job and when I was
working in a Boys and Girls Club I saw
firsthand just the incredible incredible
work they do to provide places for young
people to go to have great role models
to you know to have positive experiences
so I completely agree with you that's
really important we're actually also
spending over the course of this
Parliament 300 million pounds building
brand new or upgraded youth facilities
across the country so rest assured that
there's money there that's happening but
a million more hours of Youth provision
and the last thing you touched on was
family breakdown really important and we
have you know we have a program called
the supporting families program
which is run by councils and it used to
be called the troubled families program
for those of you that could remember it
and we've been there it's not a great
name so we've renamed how it works but
it does fantastic work because please
there they are they're wonderful right
that's not the police's primary job
right they can't fight crime and do
enforcement and also be doing all of
that now yes they they know families and
they know schools but fundamentally we
need a different approach so what the
supporting families program does is it
it has these amazing caseworkers and
they go and sit with a family and look
at the entire family's challenges and
work with them to work through them
because families are complicated right
all of our families are all they're all
complicated all the different issues
going on and it's not that
straightforward but these caseworkers
come in they talk to kids they talk to
the parents figure out what all the
different elements of the support that
the family needs that normally all exist
right in the council and in the
community and pull it all together to
help that family and that program is
doing fantastic work and I used to be
when my first ministerial job was I was
in charge of all our councils and that
that program sat under my responsibility
so I got this really amazing opportunity
to go and see the work that these people
were doing and then we because of that
you know when I got to be Chancellor I
managed to give them more money to roll
it out because they knew what a great
job it was doing but it's doing a
fantastic job and it is helping tackle
that family breakdown at a much earlier
stage help keep kids in school help keep
families together help people get into
work and that's how we'll stop you know
people ending up in a life of crime
later on but your point about conveyor
belt is really important right and
that's why this anti-social behavior is
important what we don't want is for
young people to get in bad habits at
such an early stage in their life
because we don't want people to get on a
path where they end up doing really bad
things right which is why clamping down
on antisocial behavior is really
important you know we don't want you
know that's why you know crowning on
nitrous oxide is really important we
don't want
to things which are just going to lead
to even worse crimes down the line but
your point you know really well made
right should we come over here who have
we got yes sir
hi Steve Shore chairman Johnson State
football club
um I think there's a lot of desire in
the community to do more and to actually
provide that engagement for for young
people football which I'm involved in is
obviously a great way of engaging young
people and getting to do things I do
think though that one of the challenges
we have is a lack of facilities
um you know ourselves we'd love to do
more in with our youth but we don't
necessarily have the facilities to do
that you've talked a little bit about
funding but but what else is there in
terms of planning and things like that
that are going to help organizations who
have the desire happy to spend the money
to do it because I think it's a good
thing to do in our communities but you
know we just need some support to enable
us to provide that to the to the young
people and give them that time to to get
out and and give them something to do
and enrich their lives so you're saying
the issue is a planning issue is it
I think it's a money under planning
issue and making sure that we can fight
it I mean these guys do a great job here
with the football you know I'm sure
they'd like to do more but often people
are struggling to find the facilities to
enable people to actually to put on
those that that way to engage the young
people well look that's what I was
saying to today's question earlier
that's why we're investing over this
Parliament 300 million pounds to upgrade
and expand and build new youth
facilities across the country so it
could be everything from places like
this to regular youth centers to Scouts
Huts all the rest of it so that actually
is going to be rolled out and there'll
be funding available
um but also on football in particular
we've partnered with the Premier League
and the fa and I haven't got the numbers
on top of my head but again we're
rolling out brand new 3G football
pitches
um across the country because you're
right actually is just giving young
people the opportunity to go out and
have healthy positive experiences is
really important you know it's great for
our well-being and so one thing we are
doing there will be many more football
pitches across the country as a result
of that part ownership between all of us
over this Parliament and hopefully I
don't know where the nearest one will be
to here but we'll check and get back to
you I'm sure Vicky will come and novel
me afterwards but thank you for doing
what you're doing
um that's great how is the football team
getting on good season good
doing okay
really good doing a lot better than
Southampton my team which is good right
yes um I had a gentle yeah very yes sir
we'll do anything another someone at the
back as well hello um I'm chair of the
chancellor and molden neighborhood watch
group and we're a diverse area we've got
little pockets of inner city areas and
we've got very wide rural areas can I
just ask about many hot spots I think
you're right about hotspots we have an
excellent relationship with the
community policing team
um they're very responsive when they can
the capacity though is a problem uh is
there not a concern that you'll focus on
the big hot spots at the expense of the
little hot spots and little hot spots
become big hot spots how do we get over
that particular challenge well I think
the the quick answer is you know your
local team who I spent some time with
this morning are the experts right
because they know how best to direct
their time and one thing I've been
really struck by I think here you do a
great a great job which we probably need
to learn from to spread out everywhere
Roger is uh the use of data actually and
it's just getting the collection of data
and making sure that we then Target our
resources effectively is something that
is of important part of making it work
and making sure the targeting works but
ultimately your local teams are the best
place the best people who are you know
to figure out exactly where they should
spend their time and I think we know we
know Hot Spot policing as a concept
works there's great evidence from the US
and elsewhere in the UK and we're going
to build on that in the plan with more
funding to to roll that out but your
point is Right we've got to Target it
effectively but you know rest assured
that with the data collection we're
doing we should be able to do that right
yes it was Sir at the back and then
we'll come to you as well
I probably don't need this I've got
quite a loud voice can you hear me yes
we can right um my name's Jeff Jones I'm
a resident of Chancellor I come from
great battle which is quite a nice
little area but we have got a few
problems there and I'd like to address
the problem with I've got
um about the the uprising airbnbs
which also produce anti-social behavior
um now where I live we've had a a
property redeveloped as an Airbnb it's
it's it's classed as what they call C3
usage which incorporates airbnbs and
incorporates short-term holiday let's
these places are let
um by the the owners to groups of people
with no control whatsoever they can come
in and they can use the facilities there
in this particular case they've got
10 people hot tubs karaoke rooms and
anti-social heavier and especially noise
nuisance can go on throughout the night
and there's no restriction and I think
there's really should be addressing the
pop the problems these are causing
um with maybe some regulations coming my
experience
um I think everybody's had experience
with and social behavior I have as well
but you wouldn't expect it living where
I am in an area like that where you've
got property where this is again all the
time I'm not walking the back streets of
Chelmsford and the Alleyways of
Chelmsford looking at this but it goes
on we've got a very strong
neighborhood association that works
closely with the police and and they do
an awful lot of work and I know the
police do an awful lot of work but we
still have problems and um and the the
one I particularly got is it comes from
just a property yeah you know so I think
we need I think there needs to be
something more than about this the rise
in B and B's because I think they're
becoming a problem not just insurance
but Nationwide no that's a that's a
really it's a really good point sir and
I'm sorry you're having to deal with
that right I mean it's in enormously
frustrating particularly if you've got
young kids and you're trying to sleep
and people are being disruptive nearby
so let me take that away I think I've
I've Got a Feeling we are looking at
that from from memory but I will go away
and talk about it uh with my colleagues
and figure out that we do have something
that we can do to make that situation
easier on a related topic not exactly
the same but similar just to give you
the confidence that we are thinking
about this in the plan is better powers
in faster ways to evict anti-social
tenants
um and I think that that process has
taken far too long often for local
authorities and private landlords so
what we've got as part of the plan is um
I think a halving of the time it will
take to evict anti-social tenants who
are doing exactly the same thing not on
an Airbnb capacity just as a general you
know day-to-day experience which is not
acceptable right and it goes back to
what I said at the beginning right it's
about treating people with respect right
it's about that Golden Rule right and
it's about treating your neighbors the
people who live near you with respect
and recognizing that your behavior has
an impact on them and just have common
courtesy and decency yes you should not
be you know having incredibly noisy
parties at three in the morning or
people doing all sorts of things right
that's not acceptable and that's why we
as I said strengthen the powers for
eviction of antisocial Behavior but I'll
take away the specific point on
regulation licensing and things like
that of Airbnb I appreciate it yes sir
hi
um I've I've lived in Chelmsford my
whole life so I know the streets quite
well
um I think the conservatives have
dropped the ball a little bit to be
honest
um I know it's all good talking about
this laughing gas but that is the least
of your problems
I've got an allotment
um out and it's right next to a scout
heart as well
um you have
drug deals going on outside it there's a
school nearby when I go for my walks
um there's people that are doing a lot
harder drugs I'm talking injecting so I
can only assume it's having I've
reported this
um nothing happens you don't like
gentleman said earlier you don't know
whether
it goes into the system or not
um I think I've skimmed through this
this morning
um and I personally think some of these
things are important but it's the
punishments
if someone's on drugs and they're at the
Rock Bottom a fine ain't gonna help them
you can have
um you can you can go and try and tell
them to go to community service do you
think that's actually going to work they
probably won't turn up
I'm being respectful to that but
you've got to support them to get them
out of it but also the other end is
you've got to go up to the top of the
snake and cut the head off so all these
drugs coming in you've got to get rid of
first and then you can solve out all
those little bits in between in my
opinion
yeah what you're going to do yeah
you're right
right I mean drugs drugs are appalling
right like drugs are a Scourge on our
communities on our young people and
there's a direct link between drugs and
all sorts of other crime including
violence and that's why you know we've
been particularly tough and you talk
about you know nitrous oxide laughing
gas right you know yes it it's it's not
a heroin but it's a third most taken
drug amongst young people in the country
right behind cocaine and and cannabis
and causes all sorts of trouble and it's
important that we don't have kids start
doing something which then leads on to
more serious things uh even more serious
things down the line so that's why it's
important that we do ban it and I think
that will help stop some of the things
we're talking about but more broadly
you're right about drugs right so we've
invested in a couple of things one is um
really tackling county lines
and that was a big thing working with
the police over the last couple of years
we've put more money into tackling those
drug gangs that do that and I think in
the last few years someone will correct
me if I'm wrong we've actually disrupted
about three and a half thousand County
lights
um and it's making good progress right
but of course we need to do more I agree
with you right Community sentences for
that are not appropriate and that's why
what we're doing in here is far stronger
than that those are those are criminal
offenses that carry criminal convictions
and sentences for that when people break
those rules right and actually nitrous
oxide is already illegal to sell nitrous
oxide for psychoactive reasons but you
know that hasn't obviously worked
because we all walk around and see it
everywhere and see far worse things
um so no I agree that we should have
tough sensors we do we should be
cracking down on the gangs and going up
to the the top of it we are doing that
and we will keep doing more of it sir
because you're right we don't want them
to damage our communities but we're also
going to lend on this note because you
mentioned it and you were right to
mention it right you know drugs do ruin
completely ruin people's lives right
because that's why it's right that we
have zero tolerance for them they ruin
people's lives families lives
communities lives and that's what we're
also investing in treatment and
Rehabilitation we had this very eminent
person called Carol black Dame Carroll
back do a review a couple of years ago
she came out independent report for
government of all the things that she
thought we should be doing more of when
it came to treatment and Rehabilitation
and we have funded that with several
hundred million pounds and that's going
on all the things that you would expect
us to be doing to make sure that those
people yes you know we should be
catching the gangsters and the and the
people who are supplying these things
but for the people whose lives are being
ruined we need to move them on and make
sure that they get the health support
and treatment they need as well so we're
also doing that you know so should we
should have zero tolerance approach to
drugs and make sure we stamp out
criminality we should also make sure
that we are helping the people who need
who need our support and we're doing
that too but I completely agree with you
it is appalling drugs are appalling and
no government should have any kind of
permissive attitude towards all
tolerance for them when they are doing
so much damage and rest assured that
that's what we're doing as well
all right
um yes Miss
hello I'm Rachel from Essex Council
voluntary Youth Services we've just
finished finished a listening project
with one and a half thousand children
and young people in Essex South End and
thurrock
um for our violence and vulnerability
unit around how safe they're feeling
their communities and one of the things
that they've told us is that um they
want more safe spaces they want more
trusted adults um you know they don't
want to hang around in dark Parks but
actually you know actually they're
scared of dark parks and so we need to
provide safer spaces for them you talked
about your investment in youth work and
youth services and Community groups but
how do we make sure how are you going to
make sure that that money goes to the
community groups and the youth work
groups on the ground yeah Rachel thank
you for that and thank you for the work
you're doing it's really important so a
couple of things we're doing and can you
talk about safe space is interesting
people feeling safe we're actually
funnily enough have a fund called the
safer streets fund and you know we set
that up in the wake of what happened
with Sarah everard actually and I I have
two young girls you know and it's
unfortunately it's been the case for too
long that particularly our women and
girls don't feel safe enough and that's
not acceptable and one of the things
that the safer streets fun does is
really it funds very practical local
interventions that communities bid for
Vicki's uh
oh right there we go uh and and what the
kind I don't know what it's doing here
in particular but the kinds of things
that that fund does is things like
Street lighting because you talked about
dark spaces right it's really important
you mentioned it because one of the
things you hear about repeatedly if
stuff is better lit
right people feel safer and actually it
means that criminals or people who are
just causing trouble move away so what
that fun that that fun it does things
like more Street lighting more CCTV to
exactly address the thing that you're
that you're talking about
um and I think you know Vicky's nodding
away I'm glad that you've got some of it
here
um but your point is is really well made
and those kind of practical
interventions make a difference and
they've got to be driven bottom up
because I don't know sitting in Downing
Street you know which bit of your
community is the one that needs the
extra Street lighting or a bit of Green
Space quite frankly and that's actually
why today's money is also funding green
spaces you know because green Pleasant
spaces inside urban areas are shown to
be great for you know providing a bit of
respite for people and increasing
people's well-being as well so we're
doing some more funding of that as well
but thank you for doing what you're
doing and I'm glad it's working out here
right I'm getting waved out which means
I've got to unfortunately move on to
some media questions
um as well so let me just figure out who
we've got I've got we've got BBC here
right
thank you very much indeed and nice to
be back
your expert advisors on drugs say that
criminalizing the use of nitrous oxide
will have in their words significant
unintended consequences it risks harming
children and empowering criminals have
you had enough of experts
right so on nitrous oxide
and I I saw you guys not aware when I
was talking about it right I think quite
frankly you know I and almost everyone
else is just sick of having to deal with
nitrous oxide canisters when they're
walking through their communities right
and that's it you know that it's it's
about being in your community being in
your park being on a High Street or town
center and not having to see these
things strewn around not seeing I'm just
run up I'm just trying to answer
no if you just let me answer the
question that'd be great right and it's
not just about the littering but it's
about the damage that are being done by
the people who are using it right it's
about people throwing them out of their
cars it's about people driving on it
it's about we talk you know you're very
powerful question earlier about what
drugs do more generally and I think it's
important that we have a zero tolerance
approach to drugs and that's why I think
it's important
um that we ban nitrous oxide for all the
damage that it does and it's something
that I hear repeatedly when I'm out and
about around the country from people who
say look this thing is a Scourge it's
the as we were talking about it's a
third most taken drug by young people
today right after cocaine and cannabis
that's not good right it's actually
already been banned in places like the
Netherlands right and California not
obvious places that you would think of
for doing this but they've actually
banned it and it is already illegal in
this country to sell nitrous oxide for
psychoactive uses right it's already
illegal but that also that ban is not
working because that's been that's
what's happening and there is a clear
link between it and all these other
things so for all those reasons and it
is your very powerful question sir
earlier I think it's right that we are
tough on drugs and I think this is
something that lots of people have
spoken to me in the government about and
I think it's important that we take
action uh to deal with it and that's
what I'm really pleased that we're doing
today
um can our next question from Heart
Radio
Henry Reilly from Global radio prime
minister in light of the report from the
children's commissioner today should
children as young as eight be strip
searched and on the action plan that
you've got today I note that you say the
government's on track for the 20 000
police officers by the end of the month
are you hoping there are some Catherine
K Woods among those ranks
so on on
um on the report over the weekend
you know it's obviously concerning we
take the safeguarding and Welfare of
children really seriously the police do
everyone does of course they do so you
know what I'd say on that is the iopc
gives the independent office of police
conduct is already actually looking at
some of the the higher profile cases
anyway so that work is ongoing and the
home office and the Home Secretary are
going to very carefully consider the
findings of the children's Commissioners
Rapport before deciding on the right
course of action so I can't say more
about it right now obviously we've just
got the report the home office is going
to go through it in detail and the
independent as they offered police
conduct and looking at some of the more
high profile cases as they should be
because you know we all take the welfare
and safeguarding of children seriously
and it's right that we address these
things properly so that's that's what's
happening and all the police officers
look you know
this is one of our signature commitments
and we're going to put 20 000 more
police officers on the street
um you know we're going to be there at
the end of the end of the month I think
they're a record Roger record numbers of
police officers right now in Essex which
is fantastic uh doing a great job and
look I you know yes there have been some
you know we read that we all read the
Casey reports or heard reports of it the
other week and you know appalling right
acquiringly appalling to read some of
the examples of that abuse of power that
have been happening and it's right that
we stand that out make all the changes
that are required whether that's the
mayor the new Metropolitan Police
Commissioner everyone working together
to have change you know but there are
also countless examples of police
officers doing a fantastic job in their
communities to keep us safe working very
hard to do so I had the pleasure of
meeting
um some of yours this morning and we
should also be grateful to them and
continue supporting them to keep doing
the great job that they're doing for us
too
uh next we got Sky News
can we get more police on the streets it
comes up all the time okay I think we've
spoken so we've spoken to the police and
they and the the Assumption of place is
better to get the police into cars
because they can react quickly to
incidents so they they attend incidents
and they come back what what we should
be doing is to get more police if
they're coming back from this drive
round drive around these problem areas
just so they've got a presence on the
street could we not get a little bit
more presence on the street
through this way I can understand they
might have limitations with getting
Bobbies on the beat
walking around but surely we could get a
little bit more presence on the street
so look I think that having more police
officers is a good thing that's why
we've got 20 000 more of them making
them as effective and as visible as
possible is also important right so you
know that I would leave those kind of
operational decisions to to the teams
themselves and and to Roger your
pleasing crime commissioner but I don't
you know I I broadly agree with you like
we want our police officers to be
visible and to be effective you know
part of that is you know you know it's
probably not me to micromanage how much
they're in a car versus how much they're
walking on the street but what I can do
is ensure that we're giving them the
powers they need to do their job
effectively whether it's stop and search
and other things which we're doing you
know whether it's removing as much of
the bureaucracy and paperwork from their
job as we can so they can focus on you
know actually doing the job that you
want them to do which we're doing that
as well and you know to the latest
question earlier on about making sure
that all the other bits of local
councils state government the Health
Service children's services are doing
their jobs so the police are not having
to pick up and try and do all those
other things again so they can focus on
what they want to do and what you want
them to do and so that's something we're
working on as well so we can just make
sure that our police are as effective as
possible and doing the things that we
want them to do
um right Sky News I'm getting hurried up
to uh prime minister you say in this
action plan that you're going further
than the advisory Council on the misuse
of drugs recommended well they
recommended that you tackle the illegal
supply of nitrous oxide and a Sky News
investigation you might have seen showed
that some shops are selling it without
verifying ages and even giving Balloons
with the canisters
um what are you doing about the illegal
Supply because it's not just shops of
course it's also a website and if
nitrous oxide is banned are these shops
and websites still going to be able to
continue selling these canisters yeah no
I mean you make a good point as she goes
back to the question we were talking
about earlier right and that's
technically at the moment it should
already that should none of that should
be happening there's already a ban on
selling it for psychoactive substance
for usage that that's clearly not
working and that's why it's right that
we've gone further today and what we're
going to do over the course of the
spring and the summer is consult on the
best way to do this to make sure that it
is effective tackling Supply is
important that's what we while we've
gone out after County Line gangs and
disrupted three and a half thousand of
them so we've toughened up sentencing
for for drug Supply you know it's why
the police have got those things called
project Adder for example which is a
national program to Target drug gangs in
particular so all of those things help
deal with Supply you know we need to get
the consultation right on the
implementation because obviously there
are a couple of Industries where it's
used and we need to make sure that we
you know with catering Healthcare being
the obvious examples so we need to have
exceptions for those we need to make
sure that those people still have access
to it but that needs to be controlled
and limited to them and that we can end
its Supply to young people who are then
using it in a way that none of us want
them to be doing and that's what we'll
spend the spring and the summer getting
exactly right next and six live
morning prime minister hi the chief
Constable here in Essex has raised
concern about the salaries of officers
here saying that more people are having
to turn to Second jobs and there are
officers who are having to use a Food
Bank as well here do you agree with his
call for more pay for those officers
so I I hadn't seen the specific report
but what I do know is what we've done
more broadly is accept the
recommendations of the independent body
on pay for police officers so the
government has accepted those and is
implementing those
um you know I haven't got the numbers on
top of my head but there's I think I've
gone I think from about 1500 pounds type
um increase sorry 900 more than I
thought so 1900 pound increase I think
is a minimum for police officers and I'm
glad we're able to put that uh in place
I think the broader point I'd make
though not just for police officers but
for all of you and for everyone else
public sector private sector right I
know things are difficult right I know
that you know every time you get a bill
it's gone up more than you would imagine
more than it's ever gone up and that is
having an impact on your day-to-day
living standards right and it's not
great I know that that is a number one
Challenge and that's why the top of that
list behind me half inflation the thing
that's making people feel poorer the
thing that's eating into people's living
standards the thing that's making people
be stressed about their pay settlements
is inflation it's inflation that is
driving up the cost of living it's
putting up the prices of your energy
your food and everything else it's
inflation that we need to get down and
that's why my number one priority is to
halve inflation and we've got a plan
trust me the plan will work we've got to
stick with it it's not easy it's never
easy to root inflation out of a system
but it is not some abstract economic
thing it is inflation that is the thing
that is causing all these troubles right
it's why we're having it's why you're
asking me about pay it's why you're all
struggling with energy bills it's
inflation that is doing that which is
why it's really important we stick to
our economic plan we get inflation down
and everything will feel better when we
do that I promise you right and you know
if there's nothing else I think you can
trust that I know how to manage an
economy and you've seen me do it right
once we sort this out and we get
inflation down life is going to feel a
lot better and the plan that we've got
is the right one and if we stick to it I
think you know you're going to see that
in your bank accounts you're going to
feel a lot better about things by the
end of the year all right next we've got
the Sun
prime minister we have seen anti-social
Behavior crackdowns under every prime
minister since Blair why should we
believe you you're actually going to get
this done and if I may on small boats
are you concerned this morning that
reports that your home secretary is
being seen as a sock puppet under the
influence of Tory MPS who see that your
your small boats plan doesn't quite go
far enough
look so on um cheeky with your two
questions Ryan but I'll do them I'll do
them quickly
um but look on online social behavior
and on me you I've had this job for a
few months right you guys saw me in the
pandemic you know you saw what I did you
know I said I would do these things I
deliver them in the pandemic as your
prime minister I'm very clear about what
I'm going to achieve for you you've seen
over the last few weeks we're getting
things done okay we are getting things
done right yes the situation is not easy
of course it's not easy there are lots
of challenges I'm grappling with right
but I'm working my socks off for all of
you and everyone else in this country
and you know I I only promise what I can
deliver and I'll deliver what I promise
it's as simple as that and that's what
you'll see about me there are five
things behind me they're very simple at
the end of the year you'll be able to
hand me back or country will have me
back and say well how are you doing on
these things and you'll be able to say
is he doing a good job or is he not and
I'm confident that I can deliver on the
things I tell you that I'm going to do
for you and everyone else so you know
trust me on this as I say trust me on in
inflation that we will make a difference
and look that we are you know we are
doing some significant things today
right we are making so you know we are
Banning nitrous oxide we're increasing
Hot Spot policing these are very
specific things we're expanding drug
tests we're putting more money into
youth provision these are specific
practical steps that will make a
difference on this right and that's that
oh look on on tackling boats like this
is a a massive issue right you know last
year we had 45 000 people come to our
country illegally
illegally and it's putting an enormous
pressure on the system that number has
gone up four or five times in just a
couple of years all of you have seen the
struggle we're having with hotels and
everything else the cost that all of you
are having to to pay five and a half
million pounds a day in hotel costs so
it's absolutely right that we get to
grips with this problem and we do it in
a compassionate fair and moral way and I
passionately believe that what we are
doing the way we're going to tackle this
problem is the compassionate way to do
it because ultimately all of us right
this whole country is a generous country
we want to help the most vulnerable
people in the world of course we do
right at the moment we're not able to
even do that because of what's happening
to our system which is why we've got to
get a grip on it until the Home
Secretary has done a superb job the Home
Secretary and I have worked incredibly
closely for the last few months since
we've had this job to get the
legislation exactly right it's not easy
right it is not easy we need something
that is going to be robust that's going
to be effective and that's what we've
got we've got of new law to stop the
boats has gone further than any other
government has ever done right so it is
a tough piece of legislation the likes
of which we've never seen but it's
important that it's effective which it
will be but it's also important that we
abide by our International obligations
right this is a country and a government
that does follow the law of course
that's important you know we are
confident right the Home Secretary is
confident I'm confident we've designed a
piece of legislation that will tackle
this problem and do so whilst being in
compliance with laws that we are a party
to I think that's what all of you want
right you take our reputation as a
country seriously yeah we have we have
found a way to do it we work very hard
on it the Home Secretary sat there with
me and helped do it over the next few
months and together she and I are going
to deliver it right and lastly and
quickly the telegraph
thank you prime minister just firstly on
tax briefly as it's your tax return was
issued there have been murmurings from
labor that capital gains tax should be
brought in line with income tax do you
think there is any case for that to be
examined and then just briefly secondly
on Scotland will you open discussions
with the new SNP leader on an
independence referendum so look you know
my tax returns it was something that I
promised I would do in the interest of
transparency I've done it and there'll
be a lot of focus on this that and the
other but I I think look most of you I
would imagine as everyone else say to me
is not particularly bothered by what
they are bothered about what I'm doing
for you and everyone else to help with
the cost of living and if there's one
thing that I always say when I'm doing
these things there's one policy you can
remember and I never talk about tax
policy because that's Chancellor's job
and when I was Chancellor I never loved
it when the Prime Minister started uh
commenting on tax policy but you know
we've just had a budget so you know what
we think about everything but there's
one policy to take away as this right
you know we made a difficult decision I
made a decision as Chancellor to tax the
wartime windfall profits of energy
companies exceptionally and to use that
money to help support all of you and
everyone else with your energy bills
that support is paying about half of the
typical family's Energy bill half
and it's worth about fifteen hundred
pounds right so that is what we are
doing that is what this government's
values are that's what our priorities
are and you know I said to you when I
first day I got this job I promise I'd
help with the cost of living and that's
what we're doing and that's what people
should focus on
um and you know your other what was your
other
oh right look that you know the other
people do do their thing we'll find out
today like I'm very clear that I
passionately believe in our Union right
I passionately believe in our Union I
think hopefully you know I was just in
Wales the other day announcing some free
ports which are these New post-brexit
Economic Zones that we can create that
are going to create jobs and drive
opportunity and investment I did the
same in Scotland I was happy to work
with the Scottish government to deliver
two free ports in Scotland we've worked
with the Welsh government to deliver two
freeports there I think all of you have
seen the attention and Care I've given
to resolving the situation in Northern
Ireland with the Windsor framework I
care about our Union I think it's very
precious and I always say that when my
grandparents emigrated you know to this
country they didn't come to England you
know they came to the United Kingdom and
that's because the UK represented a
really powerful set of values and
ultimately it's those values that bind
us all together it's not geography and
that idea that inspired my grandparents
to immigrate here the idea of what the
United Kingdom stood for what we were
all about as a society as a community
that is powerful it's inspiring and I
will fight very hard to protect it every
day that I'm in this job
good all right thanks very much everyone
nice to see you
[Applause]
thank you